bonsoir
bonsoir Monsieur Patrice merci d'être là
vous êtes à Calgary
[Rires]
vous êtes la première qui reçoit vous
entrez dans le panthéon de la musique
canadienne première interprète
francophone est intronisée au panthéon
de la musique j'imagine vous êtes ravi
mais j'ai cru comprendre que vous avez
été étonné aussi
ben étonné parce qu'il y aurait pu avoir
d'autres québécois
québécois après le Plamondon le
playmondon est en 2011 et aurait pu
l'avoir quand même tout ce laps de temps
c'est les musiques québécoises
de langue française puis la poésie aussi
c'est
j'ai étonné étonné parce qu'il vient
chercher un rebelle aussi étonné parce
que c'était ma condition sinequanone
c'est que je leur ai dit moi je suis j'y
vais c'est en français il y a pas je
suis un peu je parle pas anglais je vais
décider ma condition et que je suis
entouré de gens très heureux qui me
parlent français c'est comme s'il y
avait pas d'anglais du tout du tout à
part de des scandale à l'hôtel
c'est comme il était temps qui arrive en
ville autrement dit qui découvre les
grands artistes du Québec
ben oui bien oui bien oui c'est quand
même étonnant c'est quand même étonnant
bah il y a des il y a des Québécois dans
langue anglaise qui sont mais pas de
l'enfance beaucoup bon c'est une femme
qui arrive la première chanteuse Julien
contente je suis la plus âgée c'est tout
à fait normal que ce soit moi
on a mis me voir quand vous aviez 12 ans
oui je venais vous voir que j'avais 12
ans j'ai tripé
cette chanson là godbc je l'ai même
chanté dans un spectacle en 6e année je
vous adorerais je vous aime encore
beaucoup j'ai tripé sur vous c'est ça
bon ça et vous faites partie de
l'histoire musicale du Québec donc pour
moi c'est important ce soir je suis
content que le Panthéon canadien vous
accueille comme ça qu'est-ce que vous
allez chanter donc en français vous
allez parler en français c'est important
pour vous ah bah oui oui c'est très
important c'est mon identité j'ai fait
une vie en français
plus douce vous la faites avec votre
pianiste votre complice est-ce que vous
refaites parfois pour vous ou pour
d'autres vos plus vieilles chansons là
on en a entendu quelques-unes on s'est
gâtés on est remonté dans le temps mais
est-ce que vous refaites est-ce que vous
vous aimez refaire vos vieilles chansons
déjà vu que je suis vieille j'aimerais
faire des choses nouvelles
oui moi j'en fais pas beaucoup c'est à
dire qu'avec le prochain spectacle que
je fais comment ça causerie je pense à
travers
une lecture et dans la lecture je peux
me permettre de toucher à l'homme de ma
vie de chanter des chansons même que je
chantais à l'écluse quelqu'un je sentais
qu'un chantait dans les clubs donc je
repasse des petits bouts alors ça me
permet d'enchanter dans d'autres
tonalités parce que ma voix est beaucoup
plus grave c'est à cette heure-ci comme
le reste ABC la voix baissé aussi alors
on fait sauf que s'amuse les gens et
c'est bien faut avoir un certain
contexte parce que je pourrais pas
chanter j'ai 12 ans un moment où le parc
Belmont pour moi il faut quand même faut
quand même une logique aussi mais je
pourrais chanter le pack de moi encore
quelques fois mais la dernière fois j'ai
ajouté des mots en latin
des choses que je pourrais chanter mais
d'une autre manière je peux probablement
mais ça me donne une idée c'est une
bonne façon de chanter ça soit un show
d'humour peut-être aussi hein
quand est-ce qu'on vous revoie refaire
toutes ces chansons là est-ce que vous
êtes parce que vous peignez aussi les
gens savent vous exposez vous allez
réexposer vos
œuvres quand est-ce qu'on vous revoit
chanter Diane ici là je pense
on va me voir je souhaite au mois de
juillet je serai à Gatineau pour ce
concert à causeries et puis je vais
peut-être faire des trucs cet été là les
francophonie il y a d'autres spectacles
avec une symphonie donc je vais chanter
quand c'est des belles invitations j'y
vais et quand c'est le cas dans ce
concert causerie j'y vais parce que je
l'avais écrit un spectacle pour le temps
de la pandémie pour que les gens
puissent me parler descendre un peu de
son de son piédestal pour être prêt des
gens donc ça permet aussi aux gens cette
lecture et ses chansons ça me permet
aussi aux gens de pouvoir me poser des
questions donc après des chansons
j'installe une chaise et c'est le public
qui me parle pour avoir les gens ont
besoin de parler aussi de toujours voir
ça dans la lumière ce qu'il faut aller
vers les gens je vois pas souvent mais
moi quand je vais dans le monde je
laisse non mais je me retire dans mon
dans mon lit je me cache mais sinon ça
me fait toujours plaisir d'aller voir le
public ça c'est une très bonne idée que
vous avez eu là de faire ça de répondre
aux questions des gens qui viennent vous
voir il y a comme un di alogue une bulle
qui s'installe
pour la pandémie mais je savais que les
gens étaient enfermés chez eux puis
j'avais choisi une petite salle parce
que je peux pas avoir une salle de
s'emprunters
de 400 places c'était le Jésus j'avais
choisi le théâtre de Jésus il y a des
questions très très intéressantes et des
questions sur la créativité même je leur
pose des questions aussi parce que dans
notre qui va le faire des hommages mais
c'est vraiment pour répondre à des quand
les gens sont trop timides ils
m'envoient des lettres c'est très
intéressant ils vont manger chez Beauty
on voit que les gens beaucoup beaucoup
de poésie
à leur manière c'est très très ça
m'impressionne beaucoup vous savez je
prends une chanteuse moi j'étais un pont
je sais qui est un contact j'ai un
caractère spécial mais au moins je suis
un bon pont on peut pas passer dessus
et votre créativité
elle s'est déployée de toutes sortes de
façon au cours des années vous allez
leur dire quoi en deux mots ce soir dans
votre discours en français
je vais remercier parce que perdre mon
métier de show business de musique c'est
d'être entouré par beaucoup de créateurs
par beaucoup remercier tous remercier
ça ça me fait plaisir je parle un peu de
mes parents aussi qui m'ont emmené à la
première fois quand j'étais toute petite
à New York les gens allaient pas souvent
à New York j'allais à Radio Cité
musicale j'ai vu les requêtes j'ai voulu
devenir une roquette ça m'a ouvert je
remercie la première personne qui m'a
amené à Paris pour étudier le chant je
remercie aussi mon compagnon de vie que
j'ai jamais remercié mais cette fois là
je vais le faire bravo et nous on vous
remercie beaucoup Monsieur de m'avoir
invité je serais content de vivre
j'entends parce que
avec vous qui est aussi rentrent au
Panthéon d'une gentillesse infinie
monsieur John j'ai tout le temps qu'on a
on va quand même se laisser je vous
salue mes hommages on va se laisser avec
un petit bout de parc Belmont qui est
une magnifique chanson merci beaucoup à
la prochaine merci de m'avoir invité
merci au revoir